all right the last of us live action
adaptation it's out on HBO HBO Max well
the first episode is anyway but it's a
live-action adaptation of a video game
so I'm gonna be honest like it's kind of
iffy on the other hand animated
adaptations didn't do it pretty well so
now we have the HBO series and after the
first episode I gotta say they nailed a
lot in terms of tone atmosphere it's
absolutely The Last of Us it's when I
watch something like this that's an
adaptation of something or takes place
in the universe or world of something I
like to think of myself okay if I didn't
know what property this was if someone
was like hey here's a clip what do you
think this is I like to think I'd be
able to be like that's the last of us
because it looks and feels like the last
of us but what I liked about this series
is it took time to develop more about
the world so you you understand more
about the threat you understand more
about Joel's family Dynamic his
relationship with his daughter spoiler
alert for episode one by the way I
should say that you've probably played
the game anyway but spoiler warning just
being fair it really let you marinate in
a world that I like like seeing in
stories that's before the big fall of
civilization where it's like everyone's
going about their daily lives they have
no idea that this is their last day in
this world as they know it and this is
the moment I realize this show this
series is treating the audience like new
viewers they're assuming that viewers of
the show have not played the game and
you don't know how the story is going to
unfold because with this build up it's
actually kind of Epic to see it through
this lens one would assume that the
daughter is going to be the main
character like the daughter Joel Dynamic
is what's going to carry us through this
story and it kind of is in spirit Spirit
being the operative word because
she dies but in the game when Joel's
daughter died it was crushing then it
was crushing in this episode but I liked
how we got more time with Joel and his
daughter also the beginning of this
Series has this talk show interview in
the 60s I was like is that John Hannah
nice they're all sitting around talking
about pandemics they're like oh viruses
those are frightening John Hen is like
no but let me tell you about fungi and
at first everyone else at this table's
like
thanks that's scary
I told you it was funny by the end of
his monologue they're all like
more after this break which is great you
want that connective tissue with our
world it's one thing to be like yeah
we're watching a world where
civilization is falling that's
entertaining it's scary in its own right
but it's the next level kind of thing
when you can connect it to our world and
be like our world could become that
world back in the day when The Last of
Us came out and I found out that fungus
that makes these zombies was a real
thing in our world just affects ants it
doesn't affect people it's scared the
living [ __ ] out of me and I'm glad this
show this episode went a bit deeper into
it now Pedro Pascal is Joel I thought
he's great as Joel because he brings to
Joel what we need to feel in a
live-action series that's not a game see
in the game there's this
symbiotic dance that's going on between
gamer and game or gamer and and video
game character that they're playing as
rather maybe I'm projecting and assuming
everyone does this but when I'm playing
The Last of Us and I'm Joel it's not
just Joel there's a piece of me in there
too I'm projecting myself into the
character but when you have a
live-action adaptation you don't have
that you don't have that gamer
experience of the character being a part
of you and you're playing the character
as you would play this world but also
being a little more hardcore because the
game demands it casting Joel I don't
envy the task that's a difficult task to
do you have to cast someone where it's
known that they've done some bad [ __ ] to
survive this world on the basis that
they are alive and surviving in this
world but also have the human element
the human connection that thing that
links the audience to the character
where we're rooting for them in a world
where it's not a video game so you don't
have that gamer playing a character and
they're projecting themselves into the
character so that's already kind of a
stab published and Pedro Pascal does
what he does he brought that Charisma
that Humanity that relatability all
wrapped up in Joel in that he also
brings the damage he's generally most
people if they survive 20 years in this
shitty World your natural inclination
might just be no I'm not going to do
that if civilization ever Falls I will
be decent there are people like that in
this world they're called Dead you
toughen up or you die in a world like
this this world is [ __ ] that's another
thing I liked about the series it
hammers home the points it's like no
one's thriving everyone's just surviving
they're trying to get to tomorrow Bella
Ramsay is Ellie I've always been looking
forward to I'm like I think she's gonna
be a great Ellie I thought she was a
great out well I mean first episode
little lady Mormont was a scene stealer
from the get-go she's a badass I feel
like she is a little more Rough Around
the Edges than Ellie from the game I
think Ellie from the game I feel like
she was a little you know
nicer which to be fair to the world of
The Last of Us Ellie in the first Last
of Us game I was always like how did
this kid survive this long in this
shitty World whereas Bella Ramsay Ellie
a little more defiant talks a bit more
[ __ ] I buy the fact she'll stab someone
in the knee with a switchblade so
there's that in the context of the world
it completely fits and the episode ends
with that moment from the game where
they're all on their knees and they you
know they have the hands behind their
head there's one cop cop military person
officer of whatever you want to say
though in the game there are two of them
they both get shot and this one Ellie
stabs him in the leg liking the game and
Joe just beats a living piss out of him
I will say that that bite reveal was
really rushed though and it bothered me
that scenario becomes so chaotic and you
hear sirens and troops are moving in
they're like we gotta go now and they're
like you're infected Ellie she's like no
look I got a scar I got this bite a
while ago come on we gotta go like we
gotta go Joe we gotta go and then they
flee into the city where the buildings
are all jacked up like in the game and
then end credits but that reveal was so
fast so up until this point this Series
has been operating as though the viewer
has not played the game this was the
moment I felt the show was operating as
though the audience had already played
the game already knew the reveal about
the bike like it wasn't anything special
like they didn't just tell the entire
audience all the viewers hey this is the
point I felt like the conversation
needed more drama needed to take a
breath and marinate in that moment like
the game did in its cut scene with the
same reveal this girl is immune to the
thing that's turning people into walking
fungus husk zombies no let's just speed
through that like in the game Tess pulls
a gun on Ellie's like explain this [ __ ]
right now in this series that doesn't
happen why would Ellie not have a gun
pulled on her if someone sees a bite All
In All The Last of Us on the basis that
it was written by the screenwriter of
Chernobyl I was like I'm going to give
this a shot and I thought the first
episode was really good it's what you
liked from the game in execution that
delves deeper into the fungus and into
the the world into the relationships
before they end horribly and shatter a
guy's entire world and that's the reason
Joel is the way he is seeing more of
that in a Feeling more of that really
important in an adaptation it seems to
be an adapt and that wants to do the
series Justice right down to the intro
HBO always has pretty epic looking
intros and the song is the theme song
from the game titled yes The Last of Us
music is a very important thing in
entertainment it's what binds us to that
world a world actually sounds a certain
way and it does that with the soundtrack
with the musical score it's actually
been a while since I've played The Last
of Us I I want to pick up the last of us
again and play it because I own the last
of us and the remaster the remastered
remaster I haven't gotten yet because
I'm like I already own two versions of
this game paying full price for the same
game third time around just feels weird
to me still great world and as for the
first episode great adaptation I don't
know if I'm gonna talk about The Last of
Us episodes week to week like I did with
House of the Dragon I'm gonna play it by
ear but hey we'll see how it goes I
don't plan a week in advance all right
so the Last of Us episode one have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]